hey youtubers it's Charlie so in my
Walking Dead episode 11 review I asked
you guys to all submit your questions I
picked 10 of them with one fun bonus
question I've also got a new winner to
announce in my weekly giveaway if you
are finding me for the first time each
week I pick a random subscriber from the
comments to give an Amazon gift card -
just as a way to say thank you for being
so awesome round 4 will begin whenever I
post my episode 12 review next Sunday
until then everyone be sure to give
Laurey to mercury a high five because
she is this week's winner I'll be
reaching out to you on your channel for
details so now let's answer some mullets
I mean questions let's answer questions
number one
Cameron Peter asks do you think that
Rick and Carl will find out that Judith
is alive soon
I think they'll run into Carolyn
tyreese's group soon they'll probably
meet up before the season finale they're
both headed towards sanctuary I think it
will take a few more episodes at least
the show is playing this weird trick
where in the comics sanctuary comes
after Alexandria so they might be
combining those two places or they might
all get to sanctuary and leave early I
don't think they would actually combine
those two places on the show just
because they're so big in the comic
books but it'll probably be another week
or two before we find out what the show
is going to do question number two
milena Torres asks do you think the next
episode will focus on Daryl like this
episode focused on Michonne yeah based
on the teaser I think that Daryl on best
group is gonna be featured really
heavily they're just going to cover all
the people that they skipped this week
so we'll probably also see tyreese's
group and possibly Maggie's group we
didn't get a super deep look into any of
those characters during episode 10
though but the mere fact that Daryl and
Beth took up the whole teaser implies
that they'll have the biggest WTF moment
of the episode so we should all
definitely say some prayers for Beth and
maybe for Daryl - question number three
Li Chang asks do you think that they'll
ever make a prequel movie about Walking
Dead so there are a lot of rumors that
the spin-off TV show is going to be a
prequel but I don't think that's the
case it's more likely that they tell
prequel bits in comic book flashbacks I
don't really consider the flashbacks
that people on the show like Michonne
have to be prequel storylines at least
in the way I think you're implying
they're not really going to tell the
story of how the outbreak started we'll
definitely see more people on the show
have flashbacks to before the outbreak
though if you consider that a prequel
question number 4
George Barrett asks do you really think
they'd reveal a cure no I don't think
that Robert Kirkman would do
in the comic books and I don't think
that Scott Gimple is going to do that on
the show if they did that it would
automatically create this end point for
the series logically curing the outbreak
would force them to end the show at a
certain point they will end the main
show eventually just because everyone
will get burned out and people's
salaries will get too expensive but
Robert Kirkman said that'll continue to
make the comic as long as people keep
buying it which is basically forever so
as long as he keeps writing new stories
the show will have new material to draw
from the spin-off is the big test though
it's going to be completely new
characters that work in the comics if
that does well then you can bet on us
saying Walking Dead on TV at least in
some form for the next five years
meaning they do everything they could to
stop it from having a you know set end
point like a cure question number five
trucks oh nine asks do you think that
negan will be introduced this season no
or at least if he is I don't think it'll
be to the very very end in the comics he
doesn't debut till way way later than
where they are write down the show so
they'd have to skip a lot of stuff to
bring him out the hunters on the other
hand are much closer nobody on the show
has confirmed anything but I did include
a couple more hunters questions on my QA
question number six asan 121 asks well
the whole group meet up at the end of
the season well the whole group no but
I'm considering there to be several
different groups Daryl and Beth or one
Tyreese and Carol or another Rick and
Michonne or one Maggie Sasha and Bob are
another and Abraham and Glenn's make
five separate groups right now by the
end of the season I think that at least
two of those groups will merge with the
others I think that everyone headed
towards sanctuary will meet up meaning
Rick and Carl will be reunited with baby
Judith and I think that Glenn will find
Maggie meaning Abraham's group will
merge with hers that kind of leaves
Daryl and Beth on their own I think it
will be a couple more episodes before we
see groups starting to get closer to
each other so it'll probably a little
while before we actually know who will
end up meeting up question number seven
the loved one asks do you think the show
will make Abraham seem good to only turn
out to be bad later
I think Abraham's trying to do good I
don't think he's like the governor he
does give off a really aggro vibe but
it's really doctor mullet we should be
worried about
he seems way too stupid to know anything
about a cure so keep your eyes on him
for any more creepy episode ending
smiles question
number eight Jane s asks and notices the
bad guy in the porch was Jeff Kober who
always plays a bad guy do you think that
he and any of the other survivors of the
house will show up later
yes negan's group and the Savior's had
kind of a biker look to him and that
person you were talking about kind of
had a biker look to him so that
certainly doesn't apply some things my
first thought was the hunters but the
show hasn't confirmed that group will
make an appearance so for now just say
yes I just can't confirm on which group
they are you know hunters or saviors
question number nine the turtle gamer
asks do you think that Rick or Karl
could die this season
no but someone from the prison is
supposed to die at least that's the
rumor the big rumor is that the person
who's supposed to die is someone who's
still alive in the comic books I know
that sounds weird but that's just what
the rumor said which really does narrow
it down meaning Beth and Daryl would be
safe and Glenn too but it does put
Maggie on the chopping block so cross
your fingers and be prepared for a giant
WTF I think whoever it ends up being
will be surprised I was really surprised
about what happened to Herschel I didn't
know what was going to happen to him
before episode 8 question number 10
Cristian Hernandez asks would you go
find Maggie or save the world yes this
is the classic Star Trek conundrum the
needs of the one versus the needs of the
many of course I would go save Maggie
I'm a human being I'm deeply flawed
Glenn kind of represents the everyman
like the totally normal person and he's
not gonna care about anything but Maggie
for him it's not a choice at all he was
going to smash the [ __ ] out of that
window to get them to stop it only seems
like he was making a poor choice but I
actually thought that he was the only
one that was really using his brain even
though it only seemed like he was using
his heart and one last bonus question
tea baby for 86's the people in Rick's
house I got a hunter vibe from them but
if they're not hunters then who are they
so the other major group they could be
is the Savior's if you want to learn
more about them then you can check out
the comic books but the Savior's are
associated with sanctuary and negan
which is like this big looming threat in
the distance I really hope the show
doesn't go there this fast it will
probably be a couple weeks before we get
a better picture of how that's all going
to go down though there's at least one
more major new character named Gareth
that hasn't appeared yet I'm expecting
to see him either next week or the week
after that in episode 13 supposedly he's
going to be a new antagonist that's an
amalgam of a couple diff
characters in the comic books so thank
you so much for submitting your
questions this was a lot of fun as
always I tried to combine as many
answers as possible since a lot of the
questions were very similar my episode
12 review and the next round of the
giveaway will post on Sunday after the
episode airs be sure to subscribe to get
it if you haven't already the Olympics
are starting to wind down so my TV
schedules getting back to normal I'm
also starting to do weekly Hannibal
video starting this Friday so get
excited about that it's gonna be Mads
Mikkelsen vs. Hugh Dancy this season
it'll be a lot of fun right now click
here for this week's episode review and
click here to learn all about the new
companion on Doctor Who thank you so
much for watching I'll see you guys
tomorrow
high fives